[Music]
amongst all the new games that came out
in 2016 we also saw numerous reissues of
beloved classics come to playstation 4
xbox one and pc some were simply ports
with graphical upgrades while others
introduced new features and redesign
mechanics to satisfy modern tastes given
that most of these games were already
great to begin with it's not easy
picking only five to highlight but
here's what we believe are the most
impressive games that were reissued in
2016 when Japanese developer vanilla
we're open shop in 2002 the first game
it produced was PlayStation 2s odin
sphere an RPG set in a captivating World
constructed from high-res 2d graphics it
was the game's defining characteristic
and became vanilla where's calling card
earlier this year Odin sphere was
revived for PlayStation 4 as Odin Sphere
life through sir while its presentation
received the necessary upgrades to make
a look at home on hdtvs the existing
graphics translated quite well despite
their age especially with the improved
framerate on ps4 by far the more
exciting additions were redesigned enemy
AI new mini bosses smoother combo
mechanics and tweaks to inventory and
abilities based on feedback from the
original game vanillaware already had a
gem on its hands in 2007 but nine years
later odin sphere looks and plays better
than before making for one of the best
rpgs on PlayStation 4
following the remaster of gamecubes
resident evil remake for modern
platforms Capcom took the next logical
step and revived the oft-overlooked
Resident Evil 0 beyond the obvious
benefits of a bump and resolution and a
wider aspect ratio Capcom introduced an
unexpected and awesome feature that
unlocked after you beat the game Wesker
mode say what you will about Wesker's
reputation but don't knock his presence
in 0 until you take him for a spin he
doesn't need weapons Wesker can sprint
and barrel through crowds of enemies or
unleash a powerful energy blast from his
eyes to make an enemy's head explode
after impact after spending hours slowly
creeping through the shadows and
carefully managing limited ammo
replaying 0 with Wesker's powers is a
cathartic release that almost entirely
changes the tone and pace of the game
it's one of the best examples of replay
value in recent memory
[Music]
despite releasing mere months after Vita
lost in 2012 ahead of hundreds of games
to come gravity rush remains one of the
system's most memorable games when it
made the jump to PlayStation 4 earlier
this year the already great game became
even better it's vibrant graphics were
extensively remastered and his controls
were refined to take advantage of
DualShock 4's capabilities in lieu of
ADA's prominent touchscreen Blue Point
games is renowned for its work porting
games like titanfall to xbox 360 and it
does such a great job moving gravity
rush to the big screen that you'd never
know it was a handheld exclusive to
begin with according to rez creator Ted
CI music Gucci his original vision for
the 2001 game included virtual reality
but because be our technology floundered
for years both before and after Reza's
inception he ultimately had to wait 15
years to realize his dream although res
was beloved when it first came out on
Dreamcast and PlayStation 2 the
remastered version for PlayStation 4 and
PlayStation VR will go down as the
definitive version of music Gucci's
masterpiece flying through Reza's
existing stages in VR enhances the way
you absorb its colors and sounds but
area ex a new level designed just for
res infinite went off the rails allowing
you to freely fly through a shimmering
dreamscape as a whole res infinite
offers an incredible mix of sights and
sounds but area ex in particular is a
hypnotic experience unlike anything else
we've played in VR it looks bad for you
nonsense it makes me feel great smarter
more aggressive Tim Schafer has had an
illustrious career as a game designer
first at lucasarts and since founding
the studio in 2000 @ double fine
productions amidst managing teams and
contributing to games like broken age
Schafer and friends somehow find the
time to polish their earlier hits for
modern systems day of the tentacle is
the latest lucasarts game under
schaeffer's watch to be overhaul and the
upgrades extend far beyond remastering
old pixel art for HD displays the game's
controls have been modernized to retool
menus that appear directly on top of
interactive objects the entire
soundtrack is going to re orchestrate it
as well and for anyone who's curious
about what Schafer and company were
thinking during the creation of data
tentacle a commentary track provides
hours of insight as you explore the game
Dave the technical remaster revitalised
a classic game for a contemporary
audience and managed to give something
back to the fan
who've loved it all along
Oh